I found myself at some point with
a problem of creating
software libraries which was
closed locked so as to have
tools that they were secure
so I could have done what I had
done in my previous jobs,
that is-  that is to say, to look for classical languages
is classical language was n
t accessible to a population of ac
uaries because the team that I had
knew how to do big maths and there
ore it is by looking a little at what
existed as software that I
actually came across a tool that I had
heard of but I had never
manipulated which was mathematics
so I am an engineer by training I
went to two schools, arts and crafts
then the polytechnic school  which originally
gave me a background that was
very, let's say, scientific and
technical
and in fact I drifted quite quickly
towards IT
since IT was still an
important support for all these
disciplines  of engineers and I
arrived somewhat by chance due to the fact
of the job market in the world
of insurance and very precisely
reinsurance I am currently the
director of a very small company which
is a company of one  twenty
people and in this company I have
several functions I have a bit
of a one-man-orchestra function, let's say
around everything that will be strong matic
everything that will be management control
everything that will be actuarial everything
what will be financial
all that will be results on the balance sheet
etc etc so here I am in fact operating
with a single tool and mathematics has
almost all of my needs
today in this company
well so another possible subject
of use  of mathematica
obviously concerns for an insurer the
pricing part in pricing
we have in particular an important subject
since we are on
motor racing in France which is quite
complicated to price
since it is a  n risk which is very
very volatile so it must be mastered
for its mathematica is extremely
practical insofar as we can
set up tools that are a little
complicated a little heavy even if
the end user and you will see it
does not have  indeed mathematica
since in fact we are going to prepare a whole
calculation which will be analyzed here
internally we will therefore prepare an
actuarial model of pricing is the
result of this model will be put in an
excellent which will be given to the
end user which suits him  sell the contract and
do the pricing the bulk of the
calculation is done on mathematica, that is to
say that today
we are one of the few to continue in this
field because the calculation was
complicated and to my knowledge all the
other insurers who  have tried have
lost a lot of money that we
are lucky not to lose any we do
n't win a lot but at least we do
n't lose any because we have a calculation tool
powerful enough to master  ize
with a complicated model